[Musique]
ce dimanche 5 mars c'est le grand départ
du Paris-Nice il s'est lance ici depuis
les Yvelines depuis à 14 ans et cette
année c'est la commune de la verrière
qui a été sélectionnée pour le grand
départ de l'épreuve allez c'est parti
c'est une grande première pour la
commune de 6000 habitants qui a
travaillé pendant plusieurs mois pour
préparer cette journée placée sous le
signe du cyclisme très très grande
fierté pour la verrière de d'accueillir
une compétition hors normes avec des
milliers de spectateurs qui sont
attendus avec beaucoup de
téléspectateurs du monde entier qui
auront les yeux rivés sur la verrière et
le Mesnil-Saint-Denis donc c'est une
fierté on a aussi un très beau village
d'animation et j'ai pu voir beaucoup de
joie beaucoup de sourires pour tous les
âges et notamment de nombreux enfants
sur une thématique très populaire le
vélo qui parle à tout le monde qui
rassemble et donc c'est un moment unique
pour la verrière pour l'histoire le
départ est programmé à côté de la mairie
de la verrière et les verriersois sont
venus nombreux près du podium pour
suivre la présentation des équipes
j'avais plaisir parce qu'on voit un truc
comme ça donc
on le voit on voit quelque chose de bien
organisé
depuis 35 ans que je suis là
donc voilà c'est bien pour la verrière
je suis content de moi je vois le monde
que sont là à La Verrière c'est la
première fois qu'on voit faire la
verrière et je suis content
de voir en vrai le parislisme n'attire
pas que des supporters locaux la Course
au Soleil attire également des
supporters du monde entier comme ses
fans colombiens voulu soutenir un membre
de l'équipe INEO sur les routes
zivinoises on est passionné du cyclisme
depuis toute la vie mon père qui est
juste à côté depuis plus de 40 ans et
voilà on a ça dans le sang donc on est
content d'être là de partager avec tous
les tous les équipes et voilà c'est un
plaisir pour nous un public qui a pu
approcher au plus près les stars du
cyclisme les bus des équipes avaient été
installées à côté du quartier du Bois de
l'Etang le vélo va partout
le stade il couvre toute la France nous
sommes pas comme le football ou on doit
cantonner des gens dans un dans un stade
là on est vraiment ouvert au public là
depuis qu'il n'y a plus le ou moins le
covid les parkings sont sont ouverts
donc les gens peuvent toucher les
coureurs peuvent toucher les Mbappe du
vélo donc nous sommes également
satisfaits de cela les spectateurs
présents ont pu voir les deux cyclistes
les plus en vue du moment le sloven
tellage
vinguard et de quoi remporter les trois
derniers tours de France se Parigny
c'est une avant première avant que les
deux hommes s'affront de nouveau sur la
Grande Boucle cet été c'est un plateau
absolument phénoménal oui il a la
revanche du dernier Tour de France qui a
qui a enthousiasmé tout le monde
c'est formidable de l'avoir dès le mois
de mars ça va être un combat des chefs
ils ont montré dans les premières
courses de l'année en Espagne chacun de
leur côté qu'ils étaient très très forts
qu'ils ont gagné quasiment tout toutes
les courses dans laquelle ils étaient
inscrits et là c'est vraiment le combat
des chefs qui nous attend avec d'autres
coureurs de talents j'en ai très
satisfait parce que si ces coureurs là
viennent c'est que on leur propose
quelque chose de bien au niveau sportif
donc on est nous sommes vraiment
satisfaits la venue de ces sportifs de
Roland a fait le bonheur des plus jeunes
venus à la chasse aux autographes un
autographe et une photo si un grand fan
de pogacia
qu'est-ce que tu aimes bien chez lui
j'aime tout chez lui c'est une grande
chance de voir les cyclistes et je suis
très contente la première fois je vais
voir les cyclistes on va faire on va
voir les signatures et tout ah ça ça va
être cool allez prendre quelques
signatures de 5 cyclistes et ça se passe
très bien en ce moment bon là on attend
c'est sûr que c'est un peu long mais
sinon ça va là on est chaud une fois la
présentation des équipes terminées
direction la ligne de départ pour les
217 cours engagés au départ de l'épreuve
devant des milliers de spectateurs
regroupés de chaque côté de la route
[Musique]
après 169,4 km un tracé qui a conduit
les coureurs dans la vallée de Chevreuse
et la côte des 17 tournants c'est le
champion de Belgique team merdier qui
s'impose au bout de l'effort sur la
dernière ligne droite située au
Mesnil-Saint-Denis
[Musique]
deuxième jour sur ce Paris - Nice 2023
aujourd'hui le Paris-Nice partira depuis
une petite commune des Yvelines c'est
basé en ville une commune de 1500
habitants direction Fontainebleau
[Musique]
la petite commune accueille l'épreuve
pour la première fois le maire de
Bazainville a encore du mal à réaliser
aujourd'hui ce qui me plaît le plus
c'est de voir beaucoup de gens venir sur
Bazainville et j'espère que notre
village leur plaira de voir les élèves
de l'école heureux comme tout
en voyant les cyclistes les motards et
tout l'organisation je pense pas qu'on
puisse nous le reposer et donc ça sera
une fois mais je vous dis quand ça sera
fini je pense que je pourrais savourer
pour cette journée inédite la commune
avait décidé de sortir le grand jeu des
produits locaux du pays ou d'années
étaient présentés au public devant le
podium des vitrines étaient aux couleurs
du Parisis pour l'occasion vous l'aurez
compris les bazins-villois avec cocher
la dette de l'événement dans leur
calendrier pour ne pas manquer cette
course
j'avais jamais vu moi il était jamais
venu
mais c'est bien c'est très bien le
cyclisme que j'adore ça c'est pas dur
pour moi mais bon ça réveille le maire
est content c'est très bien ça vaut le
coup c'est une sacrée animation ça plaît
beaucoup je crois il y a du monde on
attendait ceci mars avec impatience on
n'a pas l'habitude de voir ce genre de
véhicule dans cette petite commune on a
pas mal de bouchons malheureusement aux
heures de pointe quand les gens rentrent
de travailler mais c'est jamais des des
bus et des vélos comme ça installer les
bus des équipes cyclistes dans des
petites communes du département c'est
l'un des objectifs affichés tous les ans
par les organisateurs chaque année dans
les Yvelines une petite commune du
département et sélectionnée c'est le
vélo qui veut ça c'est notre sport qui
veut ça et on sent on ne s'en plaint pas
les les vedettes doivent d'être partout
partout même dans les petites communes
donc pour nous c'est bien une grande
ville des Yvelines le dimanche une
petite ville le lundi un concept qui
devrait durer encore pendant de
nombreuses années le département a signé
une convention avec les organisateurs
jusqu'en 2025 vous le voyez la vallée de
Chevreuse est renommée dans le monde
entier aussi pour pour pour le vélo mon
intérêtoire qui est vraiment fait pour
le vélo parce qu'on a à la fois des
dénivelé fabuleux on a à la fois des
fleuves des forêts mais aussi un énorme
capital de Me de patrimoine qui fait
aussi que ça nous donne des images dans
le monde entier assez fabuleuses et je
crois que c'est aussi ça les Yvelines
c'est aussi territoire qui est aussi
fait pour le vélo fait pour être vu à la
télévision ce lundi 6 mars à
benzainville le départ était donné à
12h50 en présence de grands noms du
cyclisme les bazins Villois et
basins-villoise pourront dire qu'ils ont
vu dans leur communauté Deutsch
poggatcha Ionas wingegard Brian Coquard
et Tim Berli
[Musique]
le Paris Nice dans les Yvelines c'est
désormais terminé mais rassurez-vous le
Paris-Nice reviendra l'année prochaine
dans les Yvelines les prochaines villes
qui accueilleront l'étape sont connues
en début d'année à 2024